[Musica]
le ricerche ci dicono che negli ultimi
anni ci sentiamo sempre più soli
Eppure viviamo Nell'era digitale ovvero
in un mondo iperconnesso dove le
distanze apparentemente non esistono
vuol dire che posso comunicare quello
che mi accade alla mia famiglia o il mio
amico dall'altra parte del mondo e so
che loro potranno rispondermi con la
stessa velocità
in fondo intorno agli anni 2000 i primi
social network MySpace il big bang dei
social network Facebook nascono proprio
per questa ragione
avvicinare le persone aumentare la loro
interazione
in pochissimo tempo nascono così i
social network sempre più precisi e
performanti Instagram Twitter Snapchat e
WhatsApp e con loro la possibilità di
interazione diventa istantanea
vuol dire che diminuisce
progressivamente il tempo tra la
pubblicazione di un contenuto e la
ricezione quindi la possibilità di
risposta da parte degli altri
benissimo A questo punto Il problema
dovrebbe essere risolto Dovremmo
sentirci tutti meno soli
e invece no
ne è un esempio Anna che ha 14 anni
quando viene da me per la prima volta è
ripiegata su se stessa allo sguardo
fisso in basso parla sottovoce
principalmente per rispondere alle mie
domande e la cosa che mi dice più spesso
quando parliamo di lei è
non lo so
Anna viene spesso con in mano il suo
smartphone e di tecnologia sa tutto
Parla lentamente ma quando scrive sul
telefono lo fa molto velocemente
Anna Di ciò che accade online sa tutto
di lei quasi niente
a me è iscritta a diversi social network
e quando mi fa vedere alcuni dei video
che realizza per Tik Tok li trovo molto
divertente
Anna si muove su internet molto
velocemente nel mondo invece ci va coi
piedi di piombo a scuola non ci vuole
più andare
a me è connessa con tutti ma non
incontra mai nessuno
il senso di solitudine è aumentato ed è
aumentato proprio tra coloro che la
tecnologia La utilizzano meglio di
chiunque altro i giovani i nativi
digitali i nativi digitali nascono e
crescono in un mare digitale dove viene
a mancare il processo fondamentale per
la creazione di una propria identità
personale
l'incontro con gli altri
la precoce di privazione della
possibilità di relazioni interpersonali
crea degli adulti soli incapaci e
spaventati
E a proposito di adulti Silvia di anni
ne ha 54 e quando la incontro per la
prima volta mi dà subito l'impressione
di una donna solare e socievole nel
raccontarmi la sua storia ci tiene ai
dettagli alle piccole cose che per lei
sono grandi ed importanti nel parlarmi
di sé non ha esitazioni e mi dice tutto
senza che io debba chiederle niente
Silvia lavora online completamente Smart
Working quasi da un paio di anni
incontra online i colleghi si è iscritta
a un corso di pilates che segue con
delle video lezioni da casa e più
recentemente ha scaricato
un'applicazione grazie alla quale ha
incontrato online un uomo che le piace
molto
Silvia è un vulcano di emozioni e quando
comunica online lo fa utilizzando tante
parole immagini emoticon gif ci tiene le
sceglie con cura
mi dice però che raramente riceve
indietro messaggi amorevoli e che forse
Allora lei non è degna di essere amata
le persone le rispondono a brevemente
non utilizzano immagini emoticon e a
volte peggio ancora visualizzano e non
rispondono Che significa mi chiede
così Silvia passa il rassegna le
conversazioni su WhatsApp la ricerca di
un suo errore di cosa non abbia
funzionato nella comunicazione
oggi Silvia ha sempre paura di dire la
cosa sbagliata e chiede a me conferma di
sé
nel mondo di oggi quello digitale Silvia
si trova sbagliata Eppure si conosce
bene
se vi è un'identità ce l'ha ma non sa
più dov'è
nel mare delle connessioni online c'è
Chi non riesce a creare una propria
identità personale chi pur avendola la
perde
perché
perché nelle connessioni online viene a
mancare la più importante connessione
umana un processo molto difficile da
riprodurre nel virtuale
l'empatia
[Applauso]
l'empatia è quel processo di
rispecchiamento emotivo che avviene
quando due persone sono una vicino
all'altra
quando si guardano negli occhi quando si
toccano quando si sentono quando si
sentono risuonare nel silenzio
L'emozione non nasce da una parola Ma da
come quella parola viene pronunciata
dalla bocca che la grida o che la fa
tremare dagli occhi che si bagnano o che
si sgranano
l'emozione nasce da un sorriso non
sopracciglio alzato da un gesto gentile
entriamo in relazione con gli altri in
modo tanto più intenso quante più
emozioni siamo in grado di provare
e badate bene per quanto possiamo essere
bravi a spiegarle a descriverle a
descriverle sentirle è tutt'altra cosa e
ognuno di noi ha un modo estremamente
personale di sentire esprimere le
proprie emozioni
le emozioni non appartengono alla nostra
mente cognitiva quella più moderna
critica riflessiva le emozioni
appartengono alla nostra mente più
antica quella più istintiva e risiedono
in una parte molto profonda del nostro
cervello per questo le emozioni non
richiedono di essere spiegate le
emozioni richiedono di essere sentite
le emozioni hanno due caratteristiche
molto importanti La prima è la velocità
perché si innescano in millesimi di
secondo E la seconda è l'intensità
perché attivano delle reazioni
fisiologiche molto intense pensate al
cuore che ci batte forte quando abbiamo
paura di qualcosa o agli occhi che si
bagnano di lacrime quando siamo
emozionati di gioia
internet ci allena a provare emozioni
sempre più veloci e meno intense
reagiamo O meglio non reagiamo agli
stimoli sempre allo stesso modo in modo
binario on off
galleggiamo sulla superficie delle
nostre emozioni non ci immergiamo più in
nulla
Eppure la narrazione della nostra vita è
scandita dai processi emotivi vuol dire
che l'indice del libro della nostra vita
è suddiviso nei momenti più emozionanti
che l'hanno caratterizzata
in poche parole la consapevolezza di sé
la stabilità emotiva nascono
dall'incontro con gli altri
senza le emozioni senza la possibilità
di condividere di sentirle risuonare
negli altri Non esiste vita non
esistiamo noi
dicevamortimbuber una società umana
nella misura in cui i suoi membri si
confermano fra loro
in un mondo iperconnesso l'incontro
online è il primo passo nella relazione
questo oggi favorisce sicuramente un
grande numero di incontri L'importante è
però non fermarsi alla realtà digitale
sottovalutando l'importanza di
trasformare il digitale in reale
se non ci impegniamo ad alimentare il
reale non esisterà nulla di reale Nel
digitale e ogni volta che guarderemo uno
schermo ci sentiremo sbagliati vuoti
irreali
dobbiamo avere il coraggio di esistere
nella nostra reale umanità
incontrando gli altri che ci permettono
di conoscerci
scoprirci ritrovarci
a me è tornata a scuola
ha incontrato un gruppo di amiche le
confidano sempre i loro segreti perché è
molto sensibile e soprattutto dicono che
sa dare degli ottimi consigli
l'insegnante di letteratura ha detto che
è molto brava
in letteratura inglese e così Anna
incuriosita sta leggendo i miei bronzi
a disegnare nel tempo libero utilizza
l'iPad per realizzare dei fumetti
sui social network di Anna Oggi ci sono
molte cose che parlano di lei e lei che
parla di se stessa
Silvia è tornata in ufficio
incontra i colleghi durante la pausa
caffè si raccontano l'un l'altro e il
suo momento preferito della giornata lo
sa che la sua collega più stretta è
piuttosto taciturna ma poco male cioè
già lei che ha una bella parlantina sa
che lì per ascoltarla lo capisce dallo
sguardo che attenta a quello che dice
è tornata in palestra e l'insegnante di
pilates le ha dato delle correzioni
molto importanti sull'esecuzione degli
esercizi Adesso sì che si sente in forma
quell'uomo che le piaceva l'ha
incontrato ed effettivamente è molto
attraente ma dopo un paio di volte ha
capito che con lei non c'entrava nulla
internet favorisce le connessioni
trasformarle in incontri umani e la
nostra responsabilità e anche voi se vi
sentite soli se vi sentite persi se vi
sentite sprofondare in uno dei tanti
schermi che popolano la nostra esistenza
c'è una cosa molto importante che potete
fare tornare nel vostro spazio nel
vostro tempo nel vostro corpo
vivere le emozioni che a volte sono
ingombranti le distanze che a volte sono
faticose l'incontro con gli altri che a
volte ci spaventa
Ma tutto questo ci darà l'opportunità di
non perdere l'essenza della nostra
esistenza
[Applauso]
[Musica]